hello everyone and welcome to the first
Clash we'll be covering from round two
of this year's v-day World Cup it is 11
panzulia versus Magnus Carlsen as you
know Magnus along with other with some
uh 48 others uh the the top 50 from the
affiliate World rating list have been
seeded directly into round two and now
his first opponent is basically 11
points like he defeated hashabara takoti
we've checked out one game uh only we've
checked out the game that he lost but he
retaliated in round two uh they went
into the tie breaks and uh panzola came
out on top and now let's check out the
game between the two of them really a
nice one you will enjoy it features a
very very cool pause the video moment
let's check it out Levin has the wine
pieces and he opens with Knight to F3 so
the game starts off as a reti with
Knight to F6 and now on to C for
transposing into the English B6 with G3
and pawn to G6 now both players are
ready to Finca to their Bishops and the
King side Bishop to G2 with Bishop to B7
Magnus will also thinker to his light
Square Bishop D4 and now Bishop to G
seven magnets going for the double theme
kettle against this setup we have
Castles by both of them and now uh Rook
to E1 Magnus goes Pawn to E6 with Bishop
to F4 and now Pawn to D6 as you can see
very very flexible the Knight is
probably coming to D7 and C5 will be
played so Queen the C2 and now there are
some games overnight the C6 was played
also Knight after D7 is a normal but
Magnus goes for C5 right away and it is
now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game uh so live on trade
on C5 we have captors B captors and now
Knight to C3 Queen to E7 just developing
the queen uh getting ready to connect
the Rooks and of course the D6 spawn is
a backward spawn it's attacked and you
you have to be ready to defend it so
Rook 8 to D1 makes sense you want to get
this Rook away from the A1 square and
now Rook the d8 the doubling up here uh
not doubling up but doubling up on the
defense of the D6 pawn queen to D2 now
going for the Triple attack against the
D6 pawn and the Magnus nicely defends it
with Knight to E8 and and here we have
the immediate Bishop to H6 one might
also consider Bishop to G5 just to check
what Magnus will play but F6 doesn't
look all that bad here no it's a
decision you have to make do you want to
weaken uh your opponent's king or do you
want to go for Bishop to H6 right away
so 11 decided to play right away he
doesn't see F6 is being weak for for
Magnus and okay if uh if the pawn comes
here then the E5 and G5 square is again
additional protection from the pawn so
maybe it's not all that spectacular so
okay Knight to C6 we have a trade here
Bishop captures King captures and pawn
to B3 now Knight to F6 by Magnus and now
Queen to B2 nicely aligning with uh the
king and on G7 so King to G8 and now
Rook the d211 ready to double up on the
D file and put more pressure on the
d-pawn but Magnus of course will not
wait for that and he just advances it
pawn to D5 we have Pawn to E3 uh sort of
stopping deep for uh but also really
stopping it because if you just push it
then okay you do get a past Pawn here
but how are you going to defend the
Knight B5 now the pawn is attacked four
times and you cannot defend it you can
advance it to D3 but then you just
attack it once again and there is no
more way for uh black to actually defend
it so instead after E3 d captures on C4
we have B captures and now Knight to A5
putting pressure on C4 if of course you
you can capture this you win the game so
Rook capture 78 with check Rook captures
and now Knights the E5 nicely defending
the pawn and also this is a beautiful
Outpost for the Knight so Bishop
captures on G2 King characters and now
Queen to C7 putting pressure on the
Knight here and this is where things get
really really exciting now you could
consider something like Knights the B5
attack the queen Defender knightless the
queen B7 check and then F3 but much like
11 decided not to force Magnus to play
F6 Magnus decides against forcing 11 to
play F3 at least for the moment so
instead Rook to D1 now you cannot
capture the the night with the queen
because the rook and the eight is
hanging so first we have a trade and now
Knight captures also opens up a
defensive discovery on the Knight here
Queen to D6 putting pressure on the
Knight and now we have Knight back to F3
and this is very interesting as it also
the Now by playing Knight to F3 yes your
knight on D1 is hanging but also the
Knight on F6 is saying however there was
a move here that you uh have to find in
order to keep full equality and that is
Pawn to H3 uh now the reason why this is
so is that if you capture on D1 right
away then it's really not all that great
Queen to B8 with Chuck King to G7 and
now Queen captures an A7 threatens the
Knight and A5 and also the pawn and F7
so yes you are down a piece for the
moment but there's just no good move for
black if Queen to the 80 of course you
have to defend your knight then Queen
captures and F7 and if King th8 now you
just go back let's say queen to A7 you
put pressure on the Knight you still put
pressure on the pawn here and black has
to be very very careful not to get
checkmated so it's definitely white who
would be pushing here so what you might
do after H3 to prevent the loss of the
A7 Pawn is to play something like A6
first then white waste symbol with A3
and then a trade happens with United
captures on C4 Knight captures Queen
capture Sunday one and now Queen to be
it with chuck with a bit of a different
a different outcome King G7 now Knights
to D6
are getting ready to put pressure on F7
but now you can actually play Queen to
D5 check and after you move the king
let's say queen to see six stopping
Queen to C7 and black is perfectly fine
here if not better so instead after
Queen to D6 11 played Knight to F3 but
this comes with the price of a pawn so
now Magnus just captures the pawn queen
captures on D1 Queen captures an F6 and
now grabbing that pawn on C4 so now
Magnus has a past C pawn and okay the F7
Pawn is a little bit weak but uh you
know you can always just go back and
defend so 11 goes Pawn to E4 we have
Queen to D3 and now Knight to G5
attacking on F7 and also defending the
E4 pawn queen to D7 Magnus defense and
now Pawn to H4 so okay uh he he gave up
one Pawn but he wants to attack the
black king and Checkmate Magnus so H6
kicks away the Knight it makes sense
with Knight to F3 and now Queen to C6
getting ready to move the Knight also
the queen is nicely positioned here uh
aligned with the King on this dragon
Channel and once you move the Knight you
can also start advancing your path C
Pawn as uh the queen is already behind
it so we have Pawn to H5 and now uh even
Queen captures an E4 now 11 gives up one
more Pawn for the attack and it is the
absolute best move according to the
engine age captures and G6 Queen capture
Sun G6 and now Magnus just brings the
queen back Queen to F4 11 brings the
queen back Queen to F4 attacks magnus's
Knight here Queen to D3 defending uh and
now Queen to B8 with check here you have
to make a decision do you go after the
H6 Pawn or do you give a check and go
after the A7 Pawn now there's an
argument to be made for both uh I mean
this is a very nice Pawn obviously
guarding against the ideas like Knight
to G5 but if you grab the A7 Pawn then
you also have created a fast a pawn it's
just that the the C Pawn is already on
the on the fifth rank so it's a little
bit better now capturing an H6 will
yield a draw but uh going for Queen to
B8 checking to G7 and queen captures an
A7 you is now completely winning for
Magnus for one very very particular idea
so feel free to pause the video and win
the game for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always looking
uh for fun ways to sacrifice your piece
even temporarily and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight to E3 with check uh this is what
Magnus played and now there is no good
move for 11. uh of course if you go for
King to H2 then just Queen E2 there's no
defense against Queen captures on F2
you're just gonna get checkmated if King
to G1 that's even worse just Queen to F1
this even comes with checking H2 and
queen to g2's Checkmate and uh lastly
but not leastly of course F captures on
E3 which was played in the game now
comes Queen to e to with check nicely
connecting with the Knight King H3 and
now Queen captures an F3 and now the
problem is you're just down too much
material and if you capture on C5 then
look at this queen to H5 check King G4
and F5 with check uh you can either
capture with the queen or you can play
King to F4 and then Queen to E4 is
Checkmate so that's the problem you
cannot capture on C5 uh A4 was played by
11 this per prevents the combination
because after Queen the H1 check which
was played King G4 you don't have F5 as
the F Pawn is pinned but now Magnus just
goes Queen to E4 with checking to H3 and
pawn to C4 just starts advancing his
path C pawn queen to C7 11 puts a queen
behind the pawn and now King to G6 now
the F Pawn has been unpinned and you are
once again threatening Queen H1 King to
G4 and F5 check so King to H2 but now
you have to give up the A4 Pawn you
could not defend against both threats
Queen the C2 with Chuck King to H3 and
queen captures an A4 and he was in this
position on move 44 that Magnus Carlsen
or rather uh Magnus crossover 11 but
still I resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so very
nicely done by Magnus 11 played a very
very strong game but uh at that one
point where he should have played H3 and
win for that obscure line uh he decided
to give up a pawn and uh you know just
uh thought that the attack was
compensation in itself turns out but it
was it was if you play the absolute best
moves probably but it's very very hard
to do that because you know the magnets
will pretty much always play the
absolute best move uh so yeah very nice
to that and if you're wondering how to
win this is this like really really lost
uh if you're only a beginner at chess
maybe you know sometimes you don't even
resign even if you're down a piece so
why would you resign if you're down a
couple of Pawns uh there's really no
good move here let's say queen D5 which
is uh a very principled move you want to
centralize your queen you want to keep
an eye on everything you want to prevent
the pawn from going to C3 just Queen C6
and now you're either advancing the pawn
to Victory or if white blocks that you
will play Queen to H1 with check and
deliver the exact Checkmate that we
already discussed uh finishing it with
Queen D4 Checkmate uh so yeah very
nicely done by Magnus his first game in
the video World Cup and the third one
for 11 no it's actually the the fifth
one for 11 is he went into tie race
against uh Harsha baratakoti uh but yeah
a very nice number Magnus 11 will have
his chance only now it will be with the
black pieces but nowadays I I don't
think players really care whether
they're playing with white or black I
think they even feel safer playing with
black because when you're playing with
white you kind of feel that pressure
that obligation to play for the win and
with black you're just happy but uh to
play good moves maybe that's not the
mindset at the absolute top level I just
always thought it was kind of kind of a
thing I know of course Magnus always
plays for the win with any color but uh
you know who who knows uh so yeah that's
the game really hope you guys enjoyed it
if you have a favorite of your own do
use hashtag suggestion and I will gladly
go over it uh I would like to thank all
the games our best Lane Herbert said
Harper slasher and Paul Harris for a
contribution to my channel I think we
wanted to really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and of course
uh checking out all of the games that I
can manage from the fide World Cup uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
for those of you who still haven't do
check out our app for learning chess
first link in the description below and
if you really really like it give us a
positive uh score on the on the uh on
the Play store and on the App Store uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day